[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
is
[Laughter]
it's silly speaking it's it's the least
offensive part of today's show
because you know before let me just tell
you this before we get into anything
before the break we were going to be
driving across nevada and an
rv right to show you dozens of voting
addresses that don't actually exist
because there are specific rules on
youtube where um
i can be legally liable if i talk about
voter fraud
ah if i have not seen the fraud fraud
yes
so under penalty of perjury i swear
under whatever oath if i had a bible
that we will present to you today israel
we actually had dave landau who's in
third chair today how are you sir
ahoy i hate it but
uh dave landau also did us the courtesy
of going to another 10 addresses in
michigan so
we thought rather than do one show in
nevada yeah we're going to do michigan
arizona nevada and i can promise you
under a
i promise hand the cross my heart and
hope to die
these are all verified addresses which
you will see with the current newspaper
wow
that we visited so i know things are
going with mike lindell and dominion
uh and the problem is with a lot of
these situations going on publicly
i can't confirm a lot of this
information yeah everything i'm going to
show you today
will confirm it so the legwork let's see
and you know where to find me
livenorthcrider.comclub if this gets
removed if we get removed for showing
you the name
the address and images and video of the
address that does not exist we've got
about 20 for you today
and you could find hundreds of th this
is just the amount of time that we have
i don't have the time to go to hundreds
of thousands of addresses like
the time but there are lists of them uh
okay so david i know you are here hoy
how are you good how about you sir uh
terrible now
you have a show coming up i do this
weekend in appleton wisconsin
skyline not the chili the place dreams
are made of yeah not the spaghetti chili
yeah that i'm against never look back
and say like never in my wildest dreams
did i think i'd be spending a weekend at
the
appleton wisconsin skyline well yeah
i remember that was the last thing i
told to my father before he died right
did i want to play appleton
wisconsin and he reached out for your
hand and as you reach you went
and then reached for the nurse yes uh
quarterback garrett is here hey what's
up i
hate it and gerald a is here
uh but before we move on with anything
else it's actually time of course we
honor our brothers and sisters
uh who matter most more than us this
month is black history month
so
[Music]
um yeah
dave's already laughing just because he
doesn't want to be associated this
distance myself people we see a lot of
comments said oh i hope dave is
full-time you know what we're working on
it he's just he's a tough he's a tough
negotiator
he's just a tough negotiator yeah it's
better dave it's better than the
atlantis all right buddy
listen my home my home turf of the
atlantic
yeah that's his home you'll never hold
him down
he's very good at hiding so uh black
history month give us some facts there
quarterback
because no one else can uh give him i
mean yeah it's all on me it's okay
rachel dolezal made history as being the
first transracial woman
not true and she asked what how dare you
and she uh actually changed her name to
the nigerian name
uh kachi uh amir diallo yeah and you
know what that's actually that's
that's 100
i watched the documentary on netflix all
of it and
now she's shaved the front of her head
clearly to do the whole like
like she's just she's doubled down on it
that's part of her culture and she's
unemployed she's like i can't find work
well have you looked outside of the
united negro college fund have you
looked outside of the naacp
that's where her skills lie bt news host
oh my god so she got a netflix special
after being you know revealed to be a
liar
yes yeah i didn't even know that i don't
unders listen i i g
i give her credit i think the
trans-racial thing makes far more sense
yeah than the trans thing i think as
long as you look like
uh travolta in battlefield earth yeah
you're really giving it up for black
people
she's like i've seen that horse whitaker
like you know
my dad was actually offered because that
was shot in montreal my dad was offered
to be an extra because you know everyone
there's like five foot six they're all
french
and they're like oh your starting point
is six foot two and a half so we'll put
you in these platforms
and uh then he was too tall he would be
taller than travolta so
uh six weeks of filming and i remember
once we saw
what the phone was like thank god even
though he just would have been an extra
in the background
he should have done it for this wouldn't
want to run the risk of someone being
like was that was that
was that pops crowder no you don't want
that imdb credit deny it three times
before the rooster crows oh
he's got shoes on his knees like dwarf
on golf
john likes that um do we do we have the
video this just says overly okay we have
so one thing i wanted to be clear a lot
of people were saying hey i think you
might be unfair
uh yesterday with with biden saying
sticking like the blue angels when all
of them went straight into the earth
the e r n word at a munich conference
yeah and uh here's the thing susan would
you youtube
don't take don't take my word for it
right levar burton where then it's like
he points to a bunch of he's like i'm
not qualified here's a six-year-old
um i like the pop-up book book
reading rainbow aren't you the host
shouldn't i take your word for it lavar
i don't know go put on your stupid
glasses
so don't take my word for it youtube
captioning we did not do this the auto
captioning
confirms repeatedly repeatedly
and i was surprised that the captioning
actually included
the entire spelling of the n-word really
uh yeah here let's roll the clip this is
youtube captioning
on bind speech from our show yesterday
i'm either here i'm
eager to hear niggered here next
whisker but it's a bad whisker here's we
it's just a case for those who missed it
niggered here next
over here
there you have it there you have it
so youtube thank you for saving us from
a lawsuit from you
by being you you watch they will find a
way to see
all right we are gonna we're not going
to be spending too much time on a whole
lot else because i have 20 addresses to
get to you today and explain then we
have more coming down the pike
uh but of course if you are watching
this and if we get banned you can follow
us you can the podcast right a lot of
you don't know it's on apple it's on
android you can go there just leave us a
rating it helps and you can listen when
you're on the road
uh and if nothing else it's a live show
monday through thursday
10 a.m eastern that way you don't need
to rely on subscriptions and the best
thing you can do
just comment guys comment comment
comment that's the best thing you can do
on this show that's if you want to do
one thing to help us
just leave a comment it could be uh
about uh gerald's awful seth cohen polo
under a half zip hoodie early 2000
emo look comment on that this is an emo
so um here's something else i need some
eyeliner
do you play bass in a screamo band yeah
i do
do you cut your wrists just to watch
them bleed i just want to feel alive
yeah well
good luck um it doesn't help
it is weird people do that to feel alive
yeah yeah
you're gonna end up dead don't judge
dave it's almost
counterproductive yeah one would think
yeah just do drugs
amen no
no don't do drugs here's something that
happened yesterday too before we move on
to
what likely will happen here with a vote
youtube uh speaking of good old youtube
with the captioning youtube you know
what think of using by the way
just an asterisk yeah it wouldn't hurt
with those words like i use it in our
private messages getting ready for the
show where i say hey by the way
joe biden said an asterisk star you know
at symbol
r everyone's like well i think i know
what you mean but youtube's like just
put the word in there
why not there are no black deaths
i use it when i text family members i
love you
it's important it's yeah it's italian
it's how you establish trust
uh so youtube deleted dislikes on recent
biden videos
oh really yeah i think we have an
overlay right here yeah look at this and
this is uh important to note because a
lot of people say well no hold on a
second there can
just be likes and there are more likes
and dislikes um no they actually deleted
dis
this is what's important it's not they
tried to plump up the likes which
sometimes we've seen happen in the past
no dislikes disappear so this actually
uh i think we have this from
from uh is it epoch times epoch time
epic epic times i never know epic times
uh the screenshots indicate 16 000
dislikes were removed
after the adjustments the five videos on
the channel had about 14 000 likes
combined with nearly 60 000 dislikes as
of january
24th the most popular president in
history folks more votes than anyone
ever and this happened before too in the
campaign we covered it a long time ago
with um
i think was the town halls remember that
happened donald trump was really popular
and then bidens was immensely unpopular
had a bunch of dislikes
and i always sort of look i always take
it with a grain of salt when people say
hey we're being censored because a lot
of people just want to sort of deal with
that
they want that drama they want that heat
but i looked at it and it wasn't that
there were a bunch of dislikes
and then it was sort of counterbalanced
by a bunch of likes yeah the dislikes
disappeared as the ratio changed
that's and i've been on youtube since
2006 it's never happened
well 70 percent of the dislikes in that
one that we just showed disappeared yeah
they're gone that's
and it's not like the internet keeps
these images you know forever so we can
pull them up
there's no way to reference it there's
nothing scary about three companies
being more powerful than the roman
empire the ottoman empire and the greeks
combined
no crap all right um so my question to
you before we move on we're gonna have
some highlights from the garland hearing
but today is really kind of a day where
we are presenting to you some things
that i've
i've held in my back pocket and i'll
explain to you why we're just releasing
it today
but my question is what do you think is
the most convincing evidence of
fraud voter fraud in the 2020 election
some people think that it's an algorithm
that is a dominion thing
some people think that it's more about
the double voting the illegal voting the
underage voting the dead people voting
addresses that don't exist
ballots are arriving before they were
sent out right there hold
the broken chain of custody we've
covered all of these i don't think that
you need
the ghost of hugo chavez to create a
voting machine to
actually when you look at a lot of these
states separated by 10 000 separated by
20 000 just the broken chain of
custody is important yeah and we
personally had to travel out
to addresses because we can't make the
claim legally now according to youtube's
policy
at all unless i've seen it with my own
eyes we did google earth
and my half asian larabil richmond said
that's not good enough and i said i
gotta pay for a plane ticket [ __ ] you
crazy as hell
and he said that is what you have to do
and so we did it but my question to you
is what is the most convincing
evidence that you have seen relating to
voter fraud okay let's go to some uh
highlights here from the merrick garland
confirmation hearing again game has to
respect game because it's true
he was blocked and he's back he's back
he's back and
very much like a sequel it is just uh a
tedious rehash yeah we didn't like
before matter of fact it was so tedious
the hearing that as i watched it i said
there's nothing we can do with this on
the show except for a couple
a couple things that stood out at me um
first off for people who don't remember
he was a prosecutor in obama's doj so of
course we love them right
uh meaning you oversaw the fast and
furious scandals gunwalker for people
who don't remember about that the irs
targeting scandal so this guy has a
little bit of what i guess you would you
might call baggage
and if i mean little i mean he has
baggage like the junk bond uh
muppet in labyrinth you bet you need
your bet she just surround she just is
carrying trash on her back
they would make you check it yes uh so
here's one though a clip that i noticed
from the hearings that i thought was
pretty interesting
he was asked about domestic terrorism
and antifa right because he was asking
antwa attack courthouse buildings all
the stuff um
actual armed sort of insurrections and i
i
wasn't sure that i heard it correctly
turns out i did so i want to explain the
context to you beforehand because he's
unbelievably boring and woefully
inarticulate
he basically says that it's not an act
of domestic terrorism when antifa
attacks a courthouse
because it's at night time so
here's no listen now that you know
but don't take my word for it let me ask
you about
uh assaults on federal property
in places other than washington dc
portland for instance seattle do you
regard assaults on federal courthouses
or other federal property
as acts of domestic extremism domestic
terrorism
well a senator my own definition
which is about the same as the statutory
definition
it should be very much threats of
violence uh
an attempt to disrupt democratic
processes
so an attack on a uh uh
courthouse while in operation uh trying
to prevent judges from actually deciding
cases that
plainly is um domestic
uh extremism um to today junior domestic
terrorism um on a government property
at night or any other kind of
circumstances is a clear
crime and a serious one and should be
punished
who's basically at night not at night he
looks like the little kid flexing the
mirror from little giants a little bit
he does doesn't it yeah intimidation
yeah i i'm not sure that i agree with
him my definition and i think it's close
to the statue
what's that what's happening what the
what's happening are we doing uh
what's is that token is that coming from
your computer is that a haunting
what is oh are you watching the michelle
oh my god stop it stop it stop get it
off please
get it off get it stop playing first off
you should be doing your job second
you there there's a vpn on that computer
you don't want anyone tracing that
i actually don't you think rachel
dolezal has a tough time finding a job
no use a vpn so people which reminds me
actually our sponsor expressvpn you can
go to expressvpn.com
crowder and uh you get three months uh
you get three months off if you join
listen it's really don't let people
follow what you're doing online what you
do online is your own business and it's
the only vpn that i know hasn't had an
actual
security breach and still continues to
advertise on other shows
uh and we use them before they were
actually a sponsor of the show right
with the tulsi gathering stuff
on algorithms we just use expressvpn we
put our little vpn
through uh germany and uh lo and behold
we can find tulsa gabbard videos
put it back to you no so thanks
expressvpn they're actually
a product we use before they were a
sponsor and token island is gross that's
a fetish that is
fair i'm glad i'm sitting here wander
brunette is a preference
that my friend is a gross fetish so you
need to grow
[Laughter]
here's another one with garland he
wasn't familiar
this answer um when you compare it to
the kind of questioning that we've seen
and i know it's not supreme court but
attorney general
still pretty big deal his answer on
illegal border crossings it blows the
mind but
not now because we've all become numb do
you believe that illegal entry
at america's border should remain a
crime
well i haven't thought about that
question uh
i just haven't thought about that
question this is again a
question of allocation of resources um
um we will uh
the department uh will uh prevent
unlawful um uh crossing um
i don't know i you know i i have to
admit i just don't
unders i know exactly what the
conditions are and how this is uh uh
done i think if um um i don't know what
the current program even is with respect
uh to this
um if they're um so i i i assume that
the answer would be yes
jesus christ oh my god take an
improv class something yes and come on
go to the groundlings for crying out
loud
i don't know i'm not sure let me ask you
this if someone crosses the border
illegally uh uh uh we'll assume we'll
take that as a yes
um is it illegal uh uh do you think
biden just wants someone to make him
look good
yes yeah he very much does let me
explain this to you what happens is they
walk across the border
without going to the checkpoint
even though i'm going to be a g i uh you
know it's not something i thought of
with uh what do you think of well if
they do it at night it's
nice to do it at night i mean i saw some
cario
yeah it's a slow burn
it's a slower really what did you well
you know what i guess we're not getting
anywhere what did you think about uh
uh uh oh okay
i can't kill you because it's illegal
you understand that right but everyone
here feels as though
it would be a viable solution be a
benefit to me he's auditioning for world
war ii
i'd like to have dinner with you and
your family
it would just sound like the matilda
parents at their tv trays
oh my gosh by the way that's the kind of
stupid answer that you could only find
from someone who spent uh their lives in
academia
you know someone goes well you need to
look at all the listen i understand some
situations are great some situations
have nuanced
illegally crossing the border we still
consider that illegal
hmm may i consult the afro-lesbian
studies
phd right anytime let me circle back
about my job
but this is what i hate though we can't
just get a direct answer it's this guy
going through his head trying to figure
out what will get him in the least
amount of trouble right
exactly instead of just answering the
question it's the exact flip side of
donald trump we talked about this donald
trump would give you a clear answer but
then repeat it ad nauseam yeah it would
be like okay you asked me the question
if i were donald trump
uh mr trump is it going to be a crime to
continue to cross the border illegally
um it not it not only is a crime
it's one of the worst crimes it's a
haters crime that affects
people excuse me that affects people to
a degree
and it's disgusting okay when people
cross
this border illegal and that would not
be happening under my auspices
the crime okay and it is a crime folks
okay excuse me
of crossing the border like it's like we
get it yeah
it's a very clear direct answer can we
move on yeah compared with
oh uh well i haven't thought about it
well maybe you should dip [ __ ]
maybe you should think about illegal
it's in the excuse me it's in the name
illegal border crossing
that should have been yes next question
yeah and i don't know or if there was
one but i
i would have been like i'm sorry are you
serious like is that
like a joke it's in the name
and by the way for me that's a okay look
frank that's excuse me that's a problem
when it's in the name
i assume it's true the fresh prince of
bel-air
it took me months
[Laughter]
he is not a part of the royal bloodline
folks oh
no uh okay so let's go here's but here's
the thing at least we could
the one question where he could answer
really quickly okay was the one that
should be
what is the royal bluff i don't know i
just thought it was hilarious
i checked his friend dj jazzy jeff not
in the royal bloodline either that's a
problem too because look i used to take
bets
on everything and i bet that
dj jazzy jeff was going to be the next
star
i bet it all on dj jesse tjhs
i did not see that one
did not pay for the house wasn't a
nominee i'm still mad i went to 20 raves
in the 90s he was supposed to be and it
was all lies
but they can never take those glow hoops
away from you no no they can't
candy necklaces but at least he answered
really quickly and something that of
course uh you would expect maybe a
little bit of nuance because there's
disagreement not only in the science but
also the political uh fallout from it uh
but uh merrick garland
very very quick to answer on uh climate
change
do you have any doubt that human beings
are a cause of climate change
no no god at all thank you all right
you may that wasn't a trick question i
guess it wasn't a trick question
yeah wasn't a trick question like do you
believe that illegal border crossings
are illegal
uh uh uh you and your gotchas do you
believe that the illegal border crossers
could cause climate change
[Music]
that's a brain twister halliburton what
uh monsanto buzzwords what if they're
being sherpened by rachet delzell
well i don't
[Music]
we don't have that much time and this is
something i just wanted to spend some
time with you
uh and folks i do want you uh to uh
consider joining my club at
lighthouseclutter.com because do it
the policy on youtube is you can talk
about voter fraud
right you can talk about mass voter
fraud you can't suggest that it affected
the outcome of this
election totally different by the way
you can say that donald trump was a
russian pawn who was peeing on
prostitutes in the kremlin
so just to be clear um
this what i'm about to present i hope
we're in the clear because
we have proof where we actually sent our
own employees to these addresses and
verification ourselves but you can join
up at mug club we still have the promo
code fight like health 30
off i don't think we're going anywhere
you never know and uh the best thing you
can do is just
comment which one of the addresses we're
about to show you
do you think is the most egregious and
we're still working on a ton more
so um let me explain this mike lindell
is being sued by
dominion and we were looking at having
him on the show and just go with me here
for a second folks because
the problem that you have is some people
will not accept any evidence
that there is any kind of election fraud
and then you have some groups of people
who
accept any evidence wholesale look right
um
i asked for access to some of these
dominion machines we weren't able to get
it i think mike lindell is a good guy
but i will say looking at the rolodex of
some of those votes where we did our own
due diligence
they talk about addresses being switched
we did some research
some of the ip addresses are fake
they're not real and some of those
addresses listed some of those counties
listed as having votes switched with
dominion
don't use dominion software and so right
away i just it gives me
doesn't mean that it's all wrong but if
i can't have access to confirm it it's
not something i can go out and talk
about
now what i want to focus on is something
that i would swear
under oath penalty of perjury what i'm
about to present to you because
dominion isn't needed i'm not saying
that nothing nefarious happened with
dominion i just can't confirm it
i can confirm to you that these people
voted for
who may or may not be real people voted
from addresses that
do not exist so just because i don't
address some issue
relating to voter fraud doesn't mean
that i don't believe there's foul play
i do have to unfortunately hold
ourselves to the standard of
doing our due diligence and only
confirming what we've seen with their
own eyes by the way
let's contrast that with the left what
does the new york times have to say what
does msnbc have to say
no evidence of voter fraud well really
have you looked at the voter
listings have you gone to these
addresses right there's no burden of
proof on them no
there's no re there's no requirement of
any effort so
we really are held to a different
standard and um i think it's important
to focus on what we can verify
and prove and then hopefully hopefully
some of this evidence at some point
could be admitted
what i'm about to show you today has not
been admitted into any court and this is
just what we had time to see
there are thousands potentially hundreds
of thousands but i can't say i can't
confirm
yeah we just have those lists and every
single one we went to by the way every
single one we went to
was [ __ ] not some yeah you are
seeing every single address
we visited and this is what people
should have been focusing on from the
very beginning the low-hanging fruit the
easy stuff to prove
dominion should never have been the
focus in the short time frame that we
had there was no way
even if dominion is this nefarious
system like you said
you couldn't prove it in a couple of
months it was going to take a long time
to get to the bottom of that yeah
this should have been the focus from the
very beginning we made it easy for
mainstream media to go oh
they're liars look they say dominions
you know and i think and i will say this
i think that mike lindell i think
someone gave him some bad information
right yeah not all of it but with
some of the tracking the hacking look
when you look at it in a lot of those
counties don't use dominion software
and then you say that it's absolute
proof but i can tell you there's
absolute proof that some of it is wrong
but
hopefully it'll all they'll go to
discovery and we'll figure it all out in
court
uh but that's why right now we present
to you our segment
absolute proof beyond any doubt that's
super proof that for real
all right that's good yeah yeah that's
good so let me explain to you what it is
that we did
okay uh some of our brilliant
researchers here uh
on a hunch accumulated voter data
uh from government websites okay we
checked if the addresses were
deliverable by ups
and then we checked that there was a
registered property at that address so
we're going to go through them but
here's a quick snapshot collage
so you can just see boom boom boom
so we're going to walk you through all
of this wow um
and we still have many many additional
addresses to visit and again
we are starting from scratch this isn't
what i do but
lawyers people who are involved with
election integrity they're not
interested
in doing this research we've done this
research you want to sue it
you want to please make my day
make my day uh so to start this off
actually we sent one of our interns who
at that point was in nevada
to go look at some of these addresses in
nevada so uh junior choi let's bring him
out here
and uh have him talk about yeah yeah
come on in junior joy
[Music]
are you confused about where to sit
junior choi he is we did we did this in
run
through okay you need to put on your
headphones there
i love how he's sitting on the back
pillow like a booster seat it's meant to
support his lower back but he's using
like a phone
too you don't need to know that when he
was a child he made those headphones in
a sweatshirt
oh yeah i knew i recognized his people
too yeah it's pretty good
just for you candy boy oh boy
well i think this will be banned for
entirely different reasons so yeah troy
jr
first off we think you may be a
narcoleptic and you don't know it but
we'll revisit that after we did the uh
asian rosacea
worth exploring what did you think when
you were requested by us we said hey can
you go visit some of these addresses
right away did you think well this isn't
gonna be a thing well i mean like i
wasn't sure what to expect i
looked at some of the locations on uh
like on google maps using the satellite
mode and i saw that a lot of them were
empty so i'm like you know what i'm
gonna
try to get as many as possible yeah and
i was like this is actually kind of
crazy
yeah i know i remember talking to his
dad dr troy where he said you know i saw
the saw the saw the empty lot
was flabbergasted
[Laughter]
i was like oh wow you know it's like if
this happens like
you know we become uh if this is
accepted it's become a banana republic
okay the store they have a great sale
clearance oh no you're talking about
different we switched topics so let me
give you one right here we'll start off
uh we have a clip this is
by the way this is not doxing because
these are publicly available voters
right
so other people out there can do this
work and you can probably do it more
effectively than i can
579 jackson avenue
let's show the clip this is where it is
that is 579 jackson avenue
uh guess who there used to be a tent
there right maybe yeah maybe there was a
tent maybe there was an acorn
tent it could be yeah or blood drive
where they actually just inject you
with hallucinogens and steal your vote
so that was
that was just an empty lot yeah there
was nothing really there it was like a
commercial area there were some churches
next to that
like a clothing store nothing else
besides that so that's the address
is an empty church it's it's an empty
parking lot right that's all it was
well listen you can one can vote from an
empty parking lot of course
why what did you think you had to do um
let's go to the susan ray emery 1732
yale street apartment 409 right about
now on a second but
there's nothing there that one's even
detailed it's apartment 409.
lots of apartments seem to be missing it
does yeah it seems like how many
where's apartments one through 408.
well if there's a fifth floor too it's
all gone yeah all of it's gone
i mean listen if there's been a horror
but there's been some kind of a a
a controlled demolition like tower seven
i'm just asking questions then we need
to alert the authorities
this is an apartment complex was there
even an apartment complex nearby
yeah there was nearby but like most of
the places near that
actual lot were like houses oh okay
gotcha
david blaine strikes again everything
disappeared
it was copperfield half-assing it yes
now i'm gonna make this motorola
disappear do you know he uh he does his
show and it is unbelievable in vegas and
then he almost
always picks like a a a large
a bosomy blonde to make the disappear
trick and then he takes her to his
private island
oh really yes epstein the right away
he's looking for someone to disappear
and i
because he was looking and he saw my
wife because she was blonde yeah and
then he looked and
he was like um
so i want to take her now that she's
pregnant and see if he picks her
i i wandered in because i will perform
where he's at in vegas yeah yeah and
he does it with the enthusiasm
enthusiasm of a guy pumping gas
like he does not want to still be doing
magic it's just like
he pays the bills here's my robot dad
that's dead
like he just slaps things together it's
like jabberwocky's our next story like
dancing go do that
yeah although he did do that little
alien the blue alien thing
and that was unbelievable it's crazy but
you just see like he doesn't care yeah
he's dead
and he's doing amazing magic while not
enjoying it yes exactly he's like
okay that's a 55 cadillac
no that's not there yeah look at that it
was there no it's not there are you
happy
okay are you happy all right i'm going
to my island i know where it is
you don't
idiot oh you guys everywhere all of you
see a couple of street magic specials
you think you know how it's done
oh the guy who cuts himself and hovers
yeah
oh no i couldn't sit and sit in a block
of ice switching out with a double every
four hours oh my god
regular houdini someone punch him in the
oak blank
um that's how he died got punched in the
airplane okay this is another one
appleton wisconsin
this is susanna maria lopez 1009
south 17th street explain to me and by
the way that's that's the paper
uh from last week when you went out and
did it yeah and no more shooting
vertical
junior you're supposed to be
technologically capable
what was that uh well it was just an
empty
uh empty area between like a commercial
like square and a bank
and did you choose nothing there you
checked the addresses before and after
those empty lots to make sure that
the address it wasn't like just moved
yeah yeah so it just it's an address
that does not exist
it just wasn't there there's nothing
there oh it seems like i'm noticing a
trend
okay and again no proof at all you want
to see let's say these are wrong come at
me bro
so i'm armed by the industrial areas
that a lot of this happens at
yeah i mean mine will be later but
you're i saw a pattern already
yes you did see a pattern and you shot
yours in landscape mode thank you very
much and you're not even in tasteful
so uh yeah or asians every time you see
one of these images and you see it
in portrait mode think 15 an hour
[Laughter]
stephanie marie ramelli er
voted from two two one norse and of
course unless otherwise specified
uh stephanie marie romelli two two one
north spruce street is where she voted
from right about
now
[Music]
and that's the one mob that's the silver
toner see what he's showing there is
explain to people what you're showing
because you're showing the address
numbers there yeah so like the two
houses i zoomed into were 219
and 223 north bruce street and there was
no 2-2-1 in between that and i asked
one of the residents who was actually
like in front of his house at the time
if he ever heard of a 221 north booster
he says he's never heard of it so
do you think now did the person you
asked was do you think he could have
been lying to you just because you're
asian
hmm i'm not i'm not chilling that zipper
hit nothing
trying to invade aren't you trying to
take my job i saw it right now
i feel it's a different kind of
neighborhood
hey you know how to please a man boy oh
geez
you have like a gaydar for that stuff or
something what's going on that's just
all of them yeah
okay okay have you been to vegas redneck
i i i have not i have not um and which
one of these would you say by the way is
the worst of the ones that you had
visited like which one stood out at you
was it one of the ones we've already
seen is that one of the ones coming up
uh
okay one of the ones coming up actually
okay all right so let me know when you
say it's the worst one so this one is
michael travis carmen voted from 215
south casino center boulevard and that's
i know you're thinking oh he voted from
one of those buildings no no he's voting
from the
the the lawn correct yeah pretty much
there's no address wow yeah just gonna
build the grass just in the middle of
the grass voted by the way
now just right now we're going through
like 20 30 of your votes being canceled
if you
live in nevada that cancel each one of
these cancels out a legitimate vote
that's insane i'm not going for a
low-hanging fruit show was that mandalay
bay
no for real okay because it looked a bit
like mandalay bay in the background
well i don't know why would that be
low-hanging fruit you know the guy who
shot all those people
oh yeah oh that's not really a joke so
much
it's just dark that's more of a sticker
i wasn't trying to be dark
no well i would have never no no never
he did well sooner or later those
hallucinogens from your teen years catch
up with you
they do by the way are are these people
voting
in person listing that address or is
this mail and voting
on this one uh i don't know it's some
other i don't know exactly so it's just
the role we these are the roles yeah
because a lot of these things aren't
really available people think that
they've done hand recounts of the paper
ballots where their signature right
they've done recounts of the tabulations
in a lot of these things right yeah
which really at that point you just have
to trust the machine
there need to be some hand audits and
this is not me saying that the you know
the ghost of hugo chavez came in and
entered a vote 15 times what i am saying
is there are errors we know there's a
potentially three percent error
sometimes with these voting machines
and we know look i don't think we need
another boogie man as it relates to a
voting machine we have the boogeyman of
the seiu showing up in the middle of the
night with stacks of votes and not
allowing poll observers in
to the appropriate precinct there is so
much evidence
and the what's been dismissed is not the
evidence it's procedurally or yesterday
they said
the supreme court said well the case in
pennsylvania is moot it's moot because
it's definitely like it's moved because
you didn't do anything before the
election
well it's over now it's not because you
and clarence you made it over
no don't yell this is nobody's fault it
is this is yours this is your fault
and clarence thomas wrote a dissent on
that saying look we missed an
opportunity to basically make sure that
everybody thought that this election was
fine he goes
and we missed an opportunity to look
into the legality of unelected officials
changing
voting black men talking about equal
opportunity
i'm not kidding it was three comments
later it was somebody saying he would be
whipping folks so master wouldn't get
tired from a black guy and i'm like
seriously every time a black guy comes
out and says something you don't like
he's like
yeah the house person right come on the
house what i didn't know what
the hell is the house if you say it
youtube will subtitle that's it that's a
joe biden word
okay i don't like his so this is another
one here and let me know when we think
we're getting to the worst one this is
christina joy
ryan hopefully i'm getting that right
voted from 353
west bonneville avenue now
wait what was that house i don't know
did i hire you
i don't remember
molly which actually just makes me want
to party with this guy
he's got the goods bring that back up
can you pause it because it was so
short so no we don't need to look okay
so there you go there's the paper what
is this what is this
explain this to me this is what i think
is the worst one so it was like right in
a highway
underpass so wow i was in the middle of
the street like trying to take this
video so i
like didn't take it that long because
there wasn't even a way to pull over
yeah like there was nothing there like
the closest parking area was
like right up at the end of that and
there was a government building but the
thing is all private parking so i
couldn't actually park there and walk
down or i had to park like
20 minute walk away so potentially maybe
we have to someone could have voted from
that
government building may have been the
address uh no like
literally literally when i looked it up
like when i looked it up on my car gps
and on uh google maps it literally
pointed to that highway like underpass
wow yeah what kind of toyota do you
drive
no he's cool watch out oh so
i think he drives something more
expensive because a little bit more
daddy's got money
from cash doctor i'm also noticing a
trend here these names are
it doesn't seem like a lot of just
straight-up white folk names
why would you say that because i haven't
heard that
susanna maria garcia that's that's yeah
that's a straight-up white lady
my teacher was sanjay garcia she was
irish that's not true
i know not true at all i know
that's the trend of the day people can
vote and make stuff up i'll just make
stuff
oh that's true but it makes you racist
my fifth grade teacher was a white guy
named lapofana but that's probably
john el true and he says he's white
and he wears floral shirts all the time
sean penn
good friends it just makes you racist if
you question these because it's like oh
will you question all these hispanic
people's voting of course you would you
i don't know let me be clear let me be
clear because gerald is racist
no i don't have a problem with uh the
name
christina joy agupana so much
as the vote from a place that isn't a
place right
that's really my major gripe yours is
the level of melanin and the skin that's
okay that's not a grape
well the no fly list is very white it's
like
joseph yes like it's just very my friend
bob phillips is on it like they're very
very specific with white names steven
hayes was on it wasn't he because he was
like a commentator
or something stephen hayes the political
commentator yeah uh there was someone
who was
i think uh ted kennedy was on the no fly
list yeah wow yeah when people say no
fly less you shouldn't be able to buy a
gun it's like oh okay well i guess that
yeah i guess ted but can we also expand
that to cars if we're talking because
ted kennedy's on the no-fly list
yeah was he gonna drive that plane into
a lake with a woman
and change his clothes and starch his
shirt
like i've been here all night right yes
yeah ted yeah yeah can you
hey you were too drunk to remember
anything you remember me being there
last night no just tell them you did
someone stole my car and girlfriend
uh okay here's another one this one
could go either way and by the way you
could
guys can comment is your mind blown yet
because we have plenty of these i just
want to present these to you just
comment which one you think is the worst
because we want this to get out to as
many so
if you don't take the time to comment
you can't do it we're broadcasting this
live
do it when the show is archived
afterward this is the one to comment on
and start a discussion and maybe you
guys can do some research yourself
anyone can do this it just takes a lot
of time yeah uh this one
is adele bishop who voted from
2175 west a gate
uh westagate now
well let's pause that yeah so uh pause
it and then
uh junior choi you can explain to us so
what is this exactly
okay so i actually took multiple
pictures and videos of this one because
there was no uh 2175 so basically
the house numbers start from 2 7 30 and
end at 2 8 34 on that street
so there is no 2 2 1 7 5 and i looked
around the other parts of the
neighborhood
and there was nothing that went below 2
7 30 at all over there
really so yeah so like 2175 like when i
looked up on google maps like earlier it
pointed directly at the corner that
that leads into the neighborhood area
i don't know yeah not even a house
number and here's the thing
uh just so you know so you guys when if
you do your own research out there um
everything that we did on google earth
checked out
yeah but i i was again informed by my
lawyer i can't make the claim because we
could do way way way way more if we just
use google earth to confirm it i was
told unless you actually go there have
someone visit there and can you prove
that
that you can't actually claim it you
could be removed from youtube or
facebook
so you guys could do all this research
with google earth and at least that'll
give you a general idea
um and then we encourage you to at least
find some in your neighborhood but don't
take my word for it it's in a book
it's back to reading i have a quick
breaking news update from lilly actually
oh really we talked about uh robin
d'angelo and coca-cola
yeah white yeah right coke try to be
less white linkedin just took it down
they just what took down the video the
training video yep
what did lincoln cause they thought it
was racist no of course that's all
they've done they haven't said anything
so linkedin took it i hope they took it
down because it's racist
because they told you you cannot say i'm
not racist if you're white
right which seems to me to be a pretty
broad generalization about white people
i think coke is doing damage control
right now yes they're sweeping they're
like under the road please help
and it's all and all of their damage has
had to do with white right coke clear
that clear coke crystal crystal dust
disgusting crystal coke no
it's cloak clear right crystals clear
and then uh they
they have a polar bear i mean that's
pretty cool that's pretty that's pretty
great
why not a north american grizzly yeah
well that's why i wanted santa claus
that's why i drive old hummers just
because i'm tired of seeing
the coke polar bear i figure sooner or
later you know it's a slow death
yeah you just yeah they'll just turn
over to melt and just reaching for his
coke because he's in the ocean
that's what they do they show these
little kids right polar bears
they show them as these cute cuddly
woodland creatures with their seals and
their baby polar bears
right clinging to an iceberg in an
attempt to get our kids to recycle it's
just in a spirit of full disclosure show
those kids that same coca-cola bear
tearing apart a baby seal tossing his
lower intestines across
the alaskan tundra the kids who want to
buy an expedition
really quickly yeah looks like they have
a red bib
sounds awesome a red bib like they went
to a saucy crab shack
is that ordered the lobster
all right so another one gerald's going
to hate this because it's ethnic
uh he really is a racist
i am not racist and he's tall and white
he's the personification of coke clear i
have been accused of being racist
recently and i refuse to accept that
judge
he is genuinely the most racist
swipe in front of you gerald before he
should can't handle it was like is
landau a jew name
right and i was like it is but i'm not
jewish and he was like all right oh my
god he fist bumped me
he wasn't sure because that's because
right social distancing no
lawsuit when he kicked you in the nuts
that's because of the junior correct
yeah
uh christina joy
no wait did i already get through this
the gupana didn't already do that no oh
wait wait wait
that's close but it's not the same way
it's not the same name it's the same
name
no it's not yeah did you notice this it
is the same name it's the same name hold
on a second at two addresses
i didn't did you know this austin no i
didn't actually okay so the one go back
to clip d
go back to clip d bring up clip d all
right that was unless i have this wrong
here unless it was listed wrong
that's christina three five three under
the bridge
west bonneville and this one right here
is christina joy ruaya gupana
at 4389 escondido street clip f
can we confirm this wow music
i'm not even in my car at that point
is that mandolin music it's got to be
the camera
are you just are you like an uber
rolling massage parlor yeah i'm not even
that's just theme music i'm not even in
my car there i don't know how that music
is there
you know exactly how it is you're lying
okay okay is there like tequila for
asians
um let's make sure to check with lily
that i have this right yeah
and then it wasn't listed wrong because
it's the same name at another different
address now explain that one to me that
was uh with the escondido
street yeah so the escondido street one
uh i zoomed in towards the
building number because it said four
three eight six
and like i looked around four four three
eight nine but there was nothing
remotely close to that
except for that one building that had
4386 over there
so i looked around and i couldn't find
it so that was the closest thing i found
to that
and and that matched up with what we saw
on on google earth beforehand yeah yeah
so
again we had to confirm it thank you i'm
glad that we uh we have
interns and people who are willing to do
this because i cannot make the claim if
we check
tens of thousands through google earth
hey fair play i can be removed
you know who we could enlist for this to
help us i mean if only we had the
technology for this
the ups yes no no no no
no when are the when is the klan been
known for their technological
advancements
man i don't know how to open this phone
i don't unlock my own phone right
now i think we all think the masks were
a nice idea yeah
it could have been done better man's
seed room's too good for computer
hacking
yeah it's hard real hard i can't see me
i only cut one eye hole in it it's
ridiculous
i am a grand wizard the son of a [ __ ]
i'm only a
third level dragon that's it's just a
bunch of dungeons and dragons nerds
who just were like are you playing
dungeons and dragons again no we're
hating colors
what happened we lost the pieces had to
do something else
just we are not playing dungeons really
really that giant cross we ended up
burning was just a board piece that got
out of hand
look we had to get rid of two and one i
always play the cross
he's always a little wheel spindle this
guy's the boot and then at some point he
just kind of got away from us and i'm a
grand wizard of something else but you
know what
my name's on the ledger you better say
so i was gonna say that ups actually has
technology that flags addresses that
they cannot confirm exist i ship out
thousands of packages a month and i get
that all the time
how is that not possible for a state to
go hey let's just plug this in real
quick and see
if that exists it's wrong if they don't
want to uh
what if they don't want to what if
someone says hey like us right now hey
hey we're doing your job for you like
well i don't want anyone doing that job
period
oh no i understand 15 an hour
um here's another one charles delegato
voted from 5512 doe avenue
and that's just an empty lot yep austin
yeah nothing much else about that
and then there's uh stephen do we know
if that uh is that the same name voting
at two different addresses
oh we're still checking okay still uh
maybe they might need to get uh sata on
the phone here
uh phillip pingpank
okay all right that's a name sure first
off
phillip spelled with one ellen ping pang
that really seems
like a bs name yeah if it's not real
you're definitely racist for doing that
yeah
um i don't know why you're racist for
thinking that
uh erase this guy yeah
people are more than the color of their
skin gerald
pingpank voted from 7801
gomer road now
look at that so what is that exactly
that almost looks like it could be like
an airport
uh so mr pink pink over there
uh he can say that yeah it's okay
[Laughter]
but he votes every year it's glamping
it's slamping he lives in an old half
planet yes this is my cockpit i sleep
here do my civic job poop
so what is that it's so close it's
actually like me
i honestly don't know it's next to like
a bunch of uh trucking shipping yards
and that part was like i don't know it's
like a warehouse looking thing
that's all i could really figure out
from that and there was no 70801
uh that well that one area was oh that
was the area
yeah because is there like a guy at a
toll booth or something could he be
no no nothing there was nothing the only
people i saw there were on different
lots in like shipping yards like
taking uh stuff and putting them into
trucks and stuff like that so what if
it's just
underground crab people and we are being
horribly discriminatory if it's bert
groundhouse that's
all right but if it is what if that's
the natural
evolution has chosen them for
distinction but they're turning into
humans
altering the course of our elections
what if it's chuds
so many possibilities outside of the
post office didn't do
their job and this has been corrupted
you decide don't take my word for it um
thank you so much troy junior we
appreciate it you can go back on to
following assignment or doing some other
work nice
i thought the most egregious one like
obviously we still have more by the way
from dave land
people watching hit the notification
bell if you subscribe because
subscriptions don't work notification
bells don't always work so
um just watch us uh uh uh monday through
thursday ten years
just mark the page check in every
morning the empty lot one's kind of
obviously that's really bad right if
it's just but the one where they're like
well we'll just put a house between
these two houses nobody'll ever know
right
like you can walk up and take a picture
and go well i empty lot okay fine maybe
there used to be a building three months
ago yeah fine whatever
right but there's no house here right
never existed
no i mean is he from vegas uh he he's
he's nevada sometimes oh okay yeah yeah
yeah i say
the most muggable looking person
just walking around well you could give
him a run for his money when you were
driving through detroit
oil that's true we had a hidden camera
on him i mean we would have gotten
footage
i'd say you're more muggable he's more
huggable
oh that's a good point yeah that's true
you're very f but you do have a face
that sometimes i just look at you on my
fist clenches and i don't even
and i love you i love but i just like
you know it's just like it just looks
like it would just have a nice
rebound you know where there's like that
indent that just is satisfying and
you're pumping is it hitting yourself
because you want to kiss me so bad
that's what it is
i know what it is you got to beat the
guy out
that's what
then he dipped him back into a cold bath
of electrodes to his head
i'll never watch sweat into the oldies
again i promise
i'll watch it for the right reasons yeah
for that second one so the first one was
christina
joy whatever uh the second one
the escondido address the second one
that we showed yes jody d
divernay jody d okay so look
we we admit well we get it wrong that
one name there but the address
still [ __ ] we were able to correct
it and now
was wrong but the freeway was actually
yes yeah still there the freeway remains
the same a voter
and what's funny is if we hadn't
corrected that live in times notes
snopes
like oh yeah mostly false yeah exactly
because that's not who voted from this
freeway
it was john smith it's like okay but
they voted for that freeway
and that yeah but you know what we don't
need to address the rest of it
mostly fall i think i'm gonna give this
uh
two pinocchios but hold on a second look
we just presented over a dozen
yeah you know you want to make it three
oh
all right that's how it works so then we
just on a hunch decided dave landau who
was in the
wonderful city of detroit yes
represented by a giant black
fist i don't think there's a more
accurate monument
for a city than no joe lewis right there
in the middle of town
right there in the middle of town and
joe lewis of course my favorite uh boxer
that's why we named joe lewis after
he's not in here right now because he's
been a little bit uh antsy because he
had to go to the vet yesterday
and so he didn't get his wiggles out so
he's going to destroy everything oh i
don't i don't want him to just be
destroying cameras in the middle of the
show and go shoot
so yeah so you were in just
tranquilizers
yes you came in really quick because
detroit was a smaller area
so it's a smaller area to cover and you
came back with like like 10 of these
that you just did an afternoon or
something right
yeah i knew some of the areas um so i
just immediately went to those places
uh so a couple of the ones like lasser
that i didn't get they were over on the
west side but i
assure you there's not a building there
i could say that i have the proof when i
saw it i'm like really yeah
you're like listen this is enough just
take this i seriously debated i'm like i
just took a picture of any parking lot
and then if you check it you'd be like
yeah he's right
so uh here look there the good thing is
there are a lot
there are a lot of very vanilla white
names here
in detroit which actually makes it even
more suspicious
that's a little scary john williams
so john this is we'll show a clip here
uh john
williams voted from 986 this is in
michigan
central street here
okay 986 central ave is apparently a
median
and then over there is a restaurant
so it's weird
this is the very beginning for him right
someone voted from the median
and i did take pictures it was a median
i was driving up and down the street and
there was a white lady shoveling
and i just wanted to pull up and be like
why are you here
right but it's in a little area called
mexican town which is it's pretty nice
good food i highly recommend is it is it
uh largely uh
latino yeah yeah it's really it's the
best food in detroit and at night you
get stabbed so it's awesome yeah that's
nice yeah and that'll taste a messy call
but yeah it's a median i was looking for
the addresses and i'm like it couldn't
be this woman's driveway and she just
pulled in her driveway and i'm like is
this this a dress she's like no
no no and i looked and it's right there
it could be the median
where they sell cocaine it will i think
well you know what listen
do not judge oregon made it all legal
it's not uh i should let you know that
is not snow on the ground no
ah yes or dripping out of my nose
this is a mary anna banks detroit proper
mary anna banks voted from 183-56
marass morose moross ross
rose seven mile essentially okay that's
right so is that kind of like
vernier turns in eight miles yeah ross
and kelly
no one eight three five six seems to be
an abandoned building
yeah now we did confirm it was abandoned
right
oh it was yeah we're not sending people
like some guy just lives you're just
like
this isn't a band and i just like having
three parking garages in my house
can i do this can't i do this no what it
was it was attached to like a jiffy lube
so i went into that place and i was like
oh is this part of that and they're like
oh no that's just
that's empty property yeah they found a
homeless man in the elevator shaft
you're like well i have an elevator
shaft it's one floor
where will we put the homeless man he's
a biting voter
it was a giant coffin of homeless people
oh man
there was that you have to you have to
like press them in just to do the door
did you hear about those babies that
fell from the ceiling of a funeral home
in detroit like it was raining babies
during a funeral oh
yeah i guess they had just been keeping
them up there on funeral layaway
and the ceiling collection oh no i'm
dead serious yeah that's for real yeah
it actually happened well i'm not joking
they found many homeless people like
elevator shafts at grand central station
in michigan they do because they get in
there and the water comes up
right freeze but then they oh they
de-thaw on like cavemen
i don't know i'm giving them the benefit
of the doubt because i don't want to get
sued saying that it's impossible or
illegal to vote from that lot
so you be the judge don't take my word
for it it's in a book
it read and now let's go to torrance
devin martinez
now look a little diversity voted from
1-3 to i can't believe there's still so
many more of these
1326 is a shane street chain street
shane street
now this is one three two six shane and
it appears to be a field between two
apartment buildings
it's a field there were rocks though
if he did live in a rock that looked
like some nice trees a good spot to pin
a pair of uh
pleated pants yeah you could it was
definitely a nicer
area closer to downtown yeah and then
there were two apartment buildings that
were not this address
and then right in the middle uh this
park is where apparently he lives and
voted
well could there be a tree house there
could have been a tree yeah it would be
glamping it could live under there
could be glamping in detroit which is
again the elevator shift you're about to
say something token
yeah so i actually have an update on
this from sarah okay it's funny this
this morning she was like um can can
anyone please help me try and find a
triple confirm the source that this man
is is a prisoner and i was like sir
do you you have two sources i think
we're giving like yeah
this
so that that's one source her second
source was that all of these
addresses that she sent us for detroit
are residential addresses
ex i'm sorry the residential address
matches the mailing address except for
this one
the mailing address is like the county
sheriff oh wow wow
so bring up that overlay again so this
is your fans this is from a second so
this is torrance devon martinez so
we've had we have two sources confirming
because his address is a county jail
and then now we have an arrest record
right there which would suggest i think
he's probably still in prison
and he voted from bring back up cliff l
clip l so that's him that's one two 1326
shane
and it appears to be a field between two
apartment buildings
it's a field wow
wow we're finding this out in real time
again this is only so there's only so
much leg work that we can do
no evidence mind you no evidence but
that's a prisoner do you
so does that change your maybe if now
you know that he's a convicted felon yes
could have voted from that field they're
crafty well he was sitting behind me in
the car
well oh that explains it um buy that lot
yeah i'm gonna look good in that yeah
well i do live here technically i'm on
break
yeah technically i'm on furlough can you
believe they do that [ __ ] i'm not going
back
get my tenon my fighting pitbull
i just got a forward in a dress
[ __ ] i just tell them
[ __ ] it's a p.o box
i would show like some of your wife's
comb bread
oh gosh wow so a prisoner
voted from that address and again so
that's that's two
we didn't even go through those that you
know the voting people who are actually
incarcerated
uh gosh it's just the hits keep on
coming and again
and there's more there's more oh no
alejandra ramirez
and elizabeth gonzalez two people this
sounds
this sounds like a like a bs and like
ramirez and gonzalez those are the two
names i always use when i write a latino
character i'm sure there are
in may but i did have a friend named
paul martinez but i've never met
anybody it's ramirez and gonzalez
ramirez yeah
they all sound the same to him as what
he just said no martial was the last
person
nope yes it was oh yeah it was devin
martinez yeah yeah
devin martinez was the last person
trying to project his racism onto me
he's trying to soften the blow like like
a like a helicopter that really is power
and auto rotation
fan up fan up gerald okay crying out
loud
he's the racist um
all right alondra ramirez and elizabeth
gonzalez voted
in detroit from five one zero to brandon
street
now okay 5102
is either brandon 5102 brandon is either
a fence or an
ally there you go
when did the shades come out yeah uh
well oh i was
i like to pretend i'm mack tonight
um what's crazy about it is there's
nothing behind that fence
but there's no house up towards the
front and it's
it's not that property and then there's
like a bible passage written on that
fence
and then next to that is just an alley
and then the rest of the street is dogs
barking at me
but yeah they were not happy they're
trained to but yeah right across
right behind me i should have taken a
picture of that too it's a and it looked
like a very
abandoned home right but right there it
is very eerie because it's just this
fence with scripture on it and
then an alley and it's it has to be one
of those and that's why i ask if you
confirm because
um you know there's that old song that
there once was a lady who entered into
what appeared to be an abandoned home in
detroit yes
i don't know why she entered what
appeared to be an abandoned home in
detroit right
and now she died because you don't
really know in detroit
the way some folks live you think it's
abandoned and you just walk in when you
see the saran wrapped syringes and
tubing
probably best to speedy gonzales out of
there who also voted from a field
there's also the boy who cried wolf
because that's how they pronounce wolf
right yes they giving gerald a run for
his money today
yeah all right wow okay uh let's and
look we
meant all detroiters including whites ah
yes
like you got a wolf i think you meant
that was a bad joke
no that's right and that's what you hear
i'm a wolf get on your roof make it come
down like reindeer
something like that i was like some
eminem rap and there was some guy who
came in it was really big and
fat and a person of color okay
this next one is the last one we have
more that we can get to you but
uh um i would love to see you guys in
the comment section whatever work
you've done because some other people we
can't confirm we can't include it
necessarily because we can only
we can only include what we have visited
with our own eyes it's ridiculous
but you can all out there do your
experiments with google earth because
google earth or google maps right we use
a satellite view
it checked out on all of these not a
single one that we went out to visit
not one was legitimate where we said
well okay so maybe the roles
maybe the issues that we cross
referenced here no every single one this
is the last one here is
alton wesley jenkins uh voted from 1404
shane street now okay
this is 1404 shane street
apartment 1202 and it's the culminate
young
community center
which is weird it's not that weird when
you understand
the history of when you're not culminate
young it certainly fits
yeah it absolutely fits he was the guy
he was a guy who was single-handedly
destroyed he said
oh y'all bad [ __ ] hit eight
mile and he told everyone to leave
oh yeah oh he took community cinema he's
the one that put white boy rick behind
bars for 50 years because he was
basically dating his niece right oh yeah
he he was the king of corruption yeah
coleman young is is
he was the catalyst for why uh detroit
is what it is today
actually i think it was jerome kavanaugh
coleman young but he's the really
notorious one
there's a competition for king of of the
most corrupt
there right king of corruption that's
saying something and then trump pardons
him yeah
no no that was gross but also
well then there was gil hill who was
actually uh
he was the sheriff right or i'm sorry
the chief of police right which if you
guys have ever seen beverly hills cop
you know the guy yelling at axel foley
in detroit that was the real chief of
police
was it really yeah it was because
they're like we can't actually get a
chief
that's as big of a dick so they just use
the real detroit chief of police
perfect and you want and you wonder why
there are no investigations and why this
doesn't make it to court well
look that's the coleman young community
center that was the guy who established
a legacy of who was in charge of detroit
good luck finding a balanced court good
luck finding an
unbiased judge good luck having a jury
of your peers good luck getting any of
this admitted to any court
look my point is you can go through the
voter rolls right yourself
you could find i guarantee you guarantee
you
tens of thousands in these important
five states
hundreds of thousands collectively okay
well actually wait hold on a second
legally i can't see that again
it's very very very likely we have
thousands that we haven't been able to
visit
personally so if you live in an area
where you can cross-reference that
hey maybe you know what if uh if we get
a few thousand
maybe that's considered valid enough to
warn an investigation but everything you
just saw today
was never presented by the way this this
is this is something that i'm also
pissed off about okay before we leave
and by the way we're gonna take your
chat
at mug club and you'll get to see me go
work out what the hodge twins which was
fun so that was when we went to the gym
a white boy with two mostly black guys
um
what bothers me is and i can't tell you
what was going on behind the scenes i
can't tell you
who we spoke with or who where
information was exchanged but
um we did so much work to try and do and
thank you so much to sarah and thank you
so much to reg and lily and people who
helped us with this work and austin and
dave
i will tell you this the the fact that a
lot of these cases have been dismissed
procedurally is because
people were lazy and didn't do their
work
i looked at some of the evidence that
was presented from people who we thought
were in our
you know what i'll just say people like
giuliani people like sydney powell good
peep mike lindell i believe a good
person
but it was wrong i was able to confirm
that some of this evidence that they
were presenting was wrong for example
they didn't cross-reference death
certificates it was
they didn't they didn't take into
account that someone of the same name
could also have died now that being said
there
are dead people who have voted they
didn't take into account people who had
changed addresses
and people uh for example underage
voters who were of age and potentially
being registered at a certain point but
were of age when they were voting there
were so
many errors that they made it easy to be
dismissed
this is the issue with the dominion
evidence right now i hate to say it
but i went through and look people out
there who are also donald trump
supporters who are also conservatives
but but have a modicum of technical
capabilities back me up on this
those ip addresses weren't real and some
of those counties didn't use
dominion software at all it matters to
be accurate
it matters to be truthful because it
makes it too
easy for these things to be dismissed
now
because the people in positions of
control because the people
had rubes advising them with no
accountability
the burden of proof on someone like me
an entertainment a comedy host in
requiring me now to
go out to these addresses physically
with an image of today's paper and
showing you that address for fear of
being banned from the biggest platforms
on earth
it's wildly unfair of course it is not
balanced
the laws and the rules and the
guidelines are not applied equally
but the back door to allow that to
happen
was a people who led you guys by the
notes there is mass voter fraud there is
evidence of mass voter fraud
but the evidence that was presented
before and
after january 6 in many cases it was
just
ill-founded it was lazy it was poorly
done and i will never
lie to you i may be wrong but i will go
to these lengths to try and make sure to
ensure
that what we tell you is the truth
because i get pissed off when people who
have all the money
and all the pac dollars and all the
non-profit funding
just go ah it's good enough let's say 60
000 dead people voted
you're wrong and now it's made our life
harder and anyone with a youtube
channel or a facebook page or twitter
profile harder
because you screwed the pooch in not
even double checking your sources just
look at this today
live we said is that person a prisoner
we had
two verification sources and sarah i
love her she's english she's one of the
researchers said
oh i think i'm getting a bit nervous if
i don't have four or five confirming
them i don't know how much i need
because should it be a hundred and four
you have two you have his address at the
county jail
and we have the actual sentencing
sarah i love you but don't overthink it
sweetheart
he did not vote from that lot and i do
want to say that if people do look up
the culmination building they will get
an address
but the gps two of them takes you to
that
and the only other thing it could be is
a median or a field across from the
coleman a young building
i'm going for the media people look it
up well that's what they're gonna get
you know what medium
coleman young would have wanted it that
way just as youtube facebook and twitter
won it that way
uh speaking of which we are going to go
to moderate credit.com
mug club 30 off if you enter the promo
code fight like health best thing you
can do
is come are you pissed are you pissed
that the people were supposed to be on
our side didn't do their work properly
i'm pissed i'm tired of it i'm tired of
having to fight an uphill battle and
having people who are more interested in
collecting
checks than telling you guys the truth
you want to see them a paid shill
because i say their information was
wrong
while i actually sent my own workers and
went myself to verify these addresses
okay fine look i will take the risk of
being banned from any platform for the
truth
but i will not take that risk by
including people who don't have it and
aren't interested in it so
youtube thank you but you know what i
think you know this is uh this is not
bannable and i know it really bothers
you
but i don't really care everyone else
out there comment let me know if you're
pissed but youtube